[Music]
football
tell me about that as long as i have a
ball in my hand
i feel alive
kind of like how i feel right now
i'm staying here i got work to do work
the nfl is not going to draft some dude
from the 1 double a school in iowa
there were other offers i called every
team in the nfl no one's interested
[Music]
can i get one of your applications
i promised that i would take care of you
and the kids
so that is exactly what i'm gonna do
if this is your dream don't give up on
it
[Applause]
[Music]
kurt warner you got the whole package
kid
the world just needs more time to see it
he came up with this whole arena concept
arena football
it's like a circus
people love the circus i like the
surface
you pay me per touchdown i also pay you
to win oh this is gonna be fine
hey kurt we've been trying to reach you
i'm sorry who are you i'm with the rams
this guy's old
slow is molasses he's beneath the
standard of this franchise that's what
people said about me when i came here
all those years
keep something others
didn't have
go out there and you show the world what
i've known all along
you were born
[Music]
this is my time i know who i am and i
know why i'm here
[Music]
you